>>Presenter: Hi everyone.
My name's Mike Hebrew, I'm on the local author's
team.
We're always looking for volunteers so if
you are interested or have ideas we're always
looking for new ideas.
Also we have a new talk on Monday.
Nick Mason of Pink Floyd will be here, so
that should be very cool.
I met Craig about a year ago?
Two years ago?
>>Craig Ramsay: Get it right.
[Laughter]
>>Presenter: And I started
>>Craig Ramsay: A year and a half
>>Presenter: I started working out with him.
It's definitely changed my life.
I feel better about everything in general
and, so, even if you don't learn anything
he's very entertaining so
[Laughter]
>>Presenter: So everyone welcome Craig Ramsay.
[Applause]
>>Craig Ramsay: Thank you, Mike.
Well hopefully you will learn a lot which
I will make you but thank you, Mike.
And yeah, Mike and his wife Christy have been
clients of mine for about a year and a half
and I've been so impressed with Mike's transformation
over the past year and a half.
Not just his physique but what he's capable
of doing with his athleticism, it's really
impressive.
And he's such a good example of when you have
those physique goals in mind and you reach
them, your whole life changes.
It's not just about your body it's about your
body, your mind, your spirit, your work, your
family, your relationships, your future, your
present, everything.
And, also, I have today my assistant, Kevin,
who is also a client of mine and his success
story is incredible and is very impressive
to me and other clients.
He's been a great motivator and a great example
and walking billboard of what the message
can provide.
Here, give us a walking billboard back and
forth runway walk, Kevin.
Here we go.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: There we go.
Kevin, how much have you lost?
>>Kevin: Um, as of this morning I've lost
78 pounds.
>>audience members: Wow!
>>Craig Ramsay: 78 pounds in a short, how
long has it been?
>>Kevin: 10 months.
>>Craig Ramsay: 10 months but you have to
understand; when Kevin first saw me he couldn't
do a push up and couldn't even walk on an
incline on a treadmill.
And when someone comes to me, unathletic,
unlike this one that just walked in that seems
to be jacked and go to Venus Gold's everyday
which is great,
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Welcome.
Then if someone is unathletic when they come
to see me, a lot of times there's no hope
in hell in their eyes or in their mind.
And my message is it doesn't matter how old
you are, it doesn't matter what obstacles
you're up against, doesn't matter if you're
in a wheelchair, once we tackle the mind,
we tackle the body.
And what Kevin's been able to do is incredible.
And this is the message and the message is
in this book, "The Anatomy of Muscle Building."
Which all of you have and I have a more impressive
one cause it's the hard cover.
[Hitting book]
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Um, yeah, and actually great
introduction is this short video that we have
which explains not only the book but me as
the author and what I put into it.
Here we go.
[Music plays]
>>Craig Ramsay in video: My training history
started in Canada.
I was a hockey player turned contortionist,
turned ballet dancer, turned Broadway performer.
[Music plays]
>>Craig Ramsay: Nice shorts, right?
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay in video: Ten years ago my
mother was diagnosed with Fibromyalgia.
I was able to learn about my mom's condition
and change her life and pretty much save her.
Nice Vicky, this is really good!
What brought me to training and changing people's
lives stems from that.
[Music plays]
>>male #1 on video: You're here because?
>>female #1 on video: I'm here with Craig
Ramsay and we're gonna do a workout for this
area right here.
>>Craig Ramsay on video: You're pretty good.
>>female #1: Don't need a workout?
>>Craig Ramsay: You don't need a workout.
[Music plays]
>>male #2 on video: This really is a fantastic
exercise to engage all core and abdominal
muscles, you can see with Craig here.
>>female #2 on video: If someone wanted to
lose weight versus build muscle is there a
different way you would approach the strength
training program?
>>Craig Ramsay on video: There's no difference.
>>female #2 on video: Really?
>>Craig Ramsay on video: There truly is no
difference.
If you want to drop unhealthy weight you have
to incorporate a resistance training program.
[Music plays]
>>male #3 on video: Craig's book which we
have here is Anatomy Muscle Building and it
is available now.
>>Craig Ramsay on video: It's also available
on my website.
[Music plays]
>>Craig Ramsay: Kevin Rhodes.
>>Craig Ramsay on video: My training is like
a slap in the face followed with a loving
hug.
[Laughter]
>>Jackie Warner on video: All of you are going
to find your inner athlete today.
>>Craig Ramsay on video: Hop!
Hop!
Go!
[Girl panting]
>>Jackie Warner on video: Sprint it back you
guys!
>>Craig Ramsay on video: Come on hot girl!
This way then you're gonna sprint it out.
[Music plays]
>>Craig Ramsay on video: Keep that strong
run, Mandy; you've got to power this.
On!
>>female #3 on video: I met Craig Ramsay on
a reality fitness show and he changed my life.
[Music plays]
>>female #3 on video: Craig has this amazing
ability to make you wanna work hard and make
you believe in yourself.
[Music plays]
>>male #3 on video: My name is Joe.
I live in L.A. and I'm 35.
I earn my living as an event producer.
I have worked with everyone from Diane Von
Furstenberg to Doctor Dre.
[Music plays]
>>Craig Ramsay on video: Eat for fuel not
for fun.
Follow the love I have for you until you find
it for yourself.
You got this!
>>female #4 on video: Craig, I swear I'm gonna
puke!
If I vomit I'm gonna vomit on you!
>>Craig Ramsay on video: That's what soap
and water's for.
Hate me now, love me later.
[Music plays]
>>Craig Ramsay: Okay, so now you know me.
[Applause]
>>Craig Ramsay: Probably too much.
So I really wanna concentrate, obviously,
cause it's a book club but on the book, "The
Anatomy of Muscle Building" and why I wrote
this specific book and why I chose this as
my first book.
Let me let you in on a little secret that
fitness books are written by fitness professionals
for other fitness professionals.
I've read the majority of them out there and
they annoy me.
And the reason why they annoy me is because
they preach and all they do is tell you, "Okay
this is the program you need to do."
But most people don't know what that program
is or even how to start.
And the gym and fitness is a very vulnerable
experience.
And the majority of people, there's one that
knows the gym too, hey!
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: So it's my job to analyze
a body and I'm like, "Okay he spent this many
years in the gym.
This is what he does.
This is his program.
He's underdeveloped here."
And all that, so if you see my eye wandering
don't worry I'm not really judging
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: It's more out of love and
care for you.
So, I was saying the gym is a very vulnerable
place to be and, for all of us, even people
that know what they're doing.
You still have to grow and you have to change
and you need to move past plateaus.
And you need to be vulnerable enough to ask
for help with that.
So anytime anyone reaches out to me from the
show, or just from the reputation I have,
I just always feel so blessed and I tell them
what a great place that is to start from.
And I wrote this book so I'm forcing them
to reach out by reaching out to them.
I'm from Canada, from a small town in Canada
and I, unfortunately, have not been able to
spend as much time and love and attention
to my family and friends over the last ten
years because I've been in New York and L.A.
So this book is able to reach the masses and
take the message of technique.
Technique is so important when you go into
the gym and you have to know everything for
your body and that machine.
You have to be one with that machine.
So if you're doing some lame program in another
fitness book, not to demean other fitness
books by any means
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: but if you're doing a lame
and program and it says, "Oh lat pull down"
okay women are saying, "What the hell is a
lat pull down?
What's the seat adjustment?
How much weight should I be using?"
All of that, this outlines that for you and
it really sets a program in motion.
Um, let me see my notes.
I have Doctor's handwriting by the way.
It's horrible.
I'm sure all of you do too, right?
You don't have to write, you type.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: I'm behind the ages.
Um, so I wanted to discuss because Google
is such an impressive company to me and I
admire all of you very, very much and I admire
Mike and I know the long hours, the hard hours
that he puts in to work and I wanna compare
the workouts in this book to what your work
schedule is like.
You know how there's those days when you have
like a moderate work day where you can't really
give it all, all day but you're still giving
it and you're getting work done and it's taking
8 to 10 hours?
So that's your moderate day, the same thing
goes with a moderate workout day.
And let's talk about cardio, a moderate cardio
workout would be just slightly elevating the
heart rate for a long period of time, so like
40 minutes to an hour.
That's a way of burning fat off the body and
it's a body builder's way of working out without
hurting his tendons and his ligaments because
his body is so expanded, so that's your moderate
workout, cardio wise, that's gonna burn fat.
Now, when you have a deadline and you have
to work your ass off at work, the same thing
applies to the gym.
That's called interval training.
So it's when you give and then you have to
hold back and catch your breath and then you're
like, "Oh my gosh!"
You get your mind together and then you give
again.
That go and pull back, pull, go and pull back
is the goal at the gym for that and in the
book is you raise your heart rate as quickly
and aggressively as possible and then you
lower it down as quickly as possible.
So you wanna work against that adrenaline
rush that you're gonna feel and that's called
interval cardio which for most of you, I'm
really impressed, jeeze, Google's doing something
right cause ya'll are in shape.
It's great.
But interval cardio's gonna work for you then.
That's what you wanna focus on.
Putting it in terms of the book, the body
building aspect of this book is interval training.
So it's lifting heavy for, you know, 30 seconds,
you're doing 30 second hard lifting and that's
gonna raise your heart rate up more than most
cardio will and then you take your break.
Taking that break lowers the heart rate and
then you go back into it.
All of that is outlined in the book.
Now women, we've already talked a bit about
this like 10 minutes before hand when I should've
saved it for the presentation
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: So I'm sorry to bore you all
with it but women are very timid in starting
a resistance training program and unless you
have an auto immune disorder like PCOS or
you have, you know that you have higher testosterone
levels or if you're taking testosterone then
you don't have to worry about that, unfortunately,
because, Christy and Mike can vouch for this,
women have to restrict and men have to indulge.
So I'm letting you in on the secret.
Our goals are different.
And unfortunately when I have a couple that
comes to me and I'm like, "Okay, great."
So your goal for the man is to be able to
eat the buffet and enjoy it and utilize it
on your body.
And the woman, you're gonna have to restrict
cause you don't wanna be bulky, you don't
want to have all that kind of calorie intake
so we're gonna deplete your calorie per meal
and you're gonna have to sit there and watch
your husband just enjoy and indulge in all
of this amazing pizza.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: So it's always tough to do
that and it's a tough balance.
But the goals are there and they're different,
we have to understand that.
Also, Mike took me on a little tour and I
have to say I'm so impressed with what Google
has offered you as far as snacks and as far
as meals go, wow, it's so impressive, the
choices that you have, the options, so obviously
all of you are already utilizing that and
the gym you have, they know what they're doing
you all look fantastic.
Some tips that are mentioned in the book that
I would like to talk to you about is if you're
incorporating fitness into your work day then
how do you do it without looking like a total
jackass and a sweaty mess?
And there's tricks to this.
So, after your workout, wear a black shirt
after it cause you will sweat for a couple
hours after your gym workout.
You guys are able to work out during the day,
right?
How does that work?
Are you, do you have certain breaks during
the day or you can just go in when please?
>>Male #1: We wait til our bosses are gone.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Oh, okay, nice.
>>Male #2: It's pretty flexible as long as
we go to the meetings we have to go to
>>Craig Ramsay: Okay, where do I apply to
work at Google?
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: This is great.
Well, that is so supportive and I'm so impressed
with that cause breaking up your day with
workouts, even if it means like doing two
workouts like, "Okay I'm gonna separate my
cardio" you have cardio machines here too,
"Cardio and then later in the day I'm gonna
do my weights."
So impressive that you guys are able to work
on your physiques while you're able to work
and I know you guys have trainers that are
top notch and your equipment is fantastic
and it's a little different than what you'll
see in the book here but the technique is
correct.
And if you're debating if they are right or
if I'm right, I'm right.
Just so you know.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: I'll play the video again,
okay?
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: But the reason why I say that
is because my background with having been
a contortionist and now being a medically
trained fitness professional for twelve years
is the body has to be in correct alignment
when you execute all of these workouts.
And that's what the book has.
That's what the book repeatedly and annoyingly
will go over you know, feet shoulder width
apart, bent knees always, tuck the pelvis,
this is protecting your hip flexors and then
the chest is always elevated.
The shoulders are sort of pushed down and
back which is gonna now protect your rotator
cuffs, guys that's the number one injury in
the gym for us and elbows in as much as possible,
good punching wrists.
Now, taking it a step further, past the anatomy
of muscle building which it does mention,
is then going into a body building program
which has a fall script.
All this stuff will be explained once you
read the book in further detail, but fall
script utilizes the forearms and the arms
as well as the primary muscle of the chest
when you're doing, say, pushups or barbell
press.
You have to know where you fit into that program
and you have to be honest with yourself.
That's why the book outlines that and it says,
"Okay, if you can do even one day a week this
is what you do, a full body workout."
If you have two days a week we wanna separate
that into upper body and lower body.
Now, I'm guessing, because all of you are
in fairly good shape, you guys do utilize
the gym?
Put up your hand if you utilize this gym.
Yeah?
If you don't do you guys have gym options?
Do you work out at the gym?
>>Male #3: No.
>>Craig Ramsay: No?
Well, A you're doing really good you must
have some sort of sports background and you
eat properly, obviously, but what's in the
anatomy of muscle building, the pushups, the
triceps exercises, all of that can be done
from home.
And if you Google Made Man, is that right
Kevin?
Made Man dot com?
I do an amazing jug workout.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: I handle some really heavy
jugs and I take you through a routine that
can be done from home.
So there just is no excuses cause even if
you're in shape and you feel in shape the
benefits of putting lean muscle mass on you
are incredible.
They help with every aspect of your life.
I preach it until no one wants to hear me
anymore.
Women in the gym, and I mention this in the
book, and other trainers may tell you differently
but they're wrong, women have to look their
best in the gym in order to have a great workout,
in order to feel their best.
Please, even guys, don't have that mindset
of, "Oh, I'm gonna wake up and look like hell
and go into the gym."
Doesn't work, doesn't work like that cause
you don't feel your best, you don't look your
best and you're gonna be aware of that.
If, dress up, I'm not saying you're gonna
be in full beat with eyelashes out to here
and you're gonna be doing "Chicago" the musical
but you definitely have to wear something
that's appropriate that makes you feel good,
even guys, it does aid in your workouts.
First off, does anyone have any questions
so far?
Don't be shy.
Yep?
>>female #1: Could you actually talk a little
bit more about the nutrition differences that
you just got into between men and women?
I know some of it can be a little more specific
when we started working together
>>Craig Ramsay: Yeah.
>>female #1:there's carbs after a certain
time and things like that and the way men,
sort of, need to eat after a workout.
>>Craig Ramsay: And before, yeah, let's start
with breakfast first.
Is these snack bars open right in the morning
for you guys?
>>audience member: We have a full kitchen.
>>Craig Ramsay: Excuse me
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: this is amazing.
Can I just get a Google pass at least?
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Venice Gold's, I'll just come
a little bit early and have a buffet
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: It's great.
I have the oatmeal options you have and fruit,
you have fresh fruit, correct?
So that's an incredible start to your morning.
If there's protein options, didn't I see hardboiled
eggs?
>>audience member: Yeah we usually have hard
boiled eggs.
>>Craig Ramsay: Perfect.
So starting your breakfast off, when you wake
up in the morning you should have it within
a half hour of waking up.
If you don't and you don't eat you're slowing
down your metabolism.
Also, if you're taking a sip of coffee prior
to putting food in your system you're slowing
down your metabolism.
That ring around here is near impossible to
get rid of unless you have those fitness model
tips.
And how many of you drink coffee in the morning
on an empty stomach?
Yeah?
That's slowing down your metabolism like crazy
and it packs on fat around the mid section.
The same with going without eating for 3 hours
and I'm not saying you should indulge every
3 hours.
As we talked about with men and women, especially
women, you have to break up your meals as
if they're snacks.
And I don't like to get in the habit of calorie
counting because women can be obsessed with
that.
What you should know is the good foods and
the bad foods and the ugly and the ugly is
sugar.
Sugar is just not a necessity and if you think
fake sugars like Splenda and all of that are
gonna be fine, they're not because they're
gonna drive you insane mentally because it's
gonna perpetuate more sugar cravings.
So you just need to cut out that crap.
Unfortunately there's just no way around it.
You can have it every 10 days or so, a cheat
meal is fantastic and once you're at the fitness
level of most of you, actually to be honest,
then you can have a cheat day and then we
just go crazy on it and we love it, right?
But the trick is to get back on track after
you have that horribly indulgent day.
That's where your body gets back into a shock
mode where it's like, "Oh, alright, then we
don't need to store into this fat."
We deplete it and we're back on track.
And you do that every 10 days, it's a health
thing.
It has nothing to do with just the mind, it's
a mind and body thing that's necessary to
do.
So women, the breakfast, ideally you have
it right here.
Your oatmeal, your eggs, your fresh fruit
and peanut butter, peanut butter is gonna
be your best friend, women especially.
When we incorporate a good fat like peanut
butter and avocados with really good carb
it slows down the digestion of carb.
So, say I had peanut butter with oatmeal,
normally that would take 40 minutes to shock
my system and it would be depleted, right?
And then we could get hungry sooner and we'll
have ups and downs.
You'll find a chemical change in your body.
If you have peanut butter with that it slows
down the digestion of that carb.
So now you're being fed, slowly, food over
a two hour period instead of 40 minutes.
So that's why they say eat good fats to lose
weight.
It's good fats with carbs.
One online training client, cause I offer
online training through fit orbit, and all
of that is outlined with, they utilize the
book by the way, the workouts in the book,
but the food program one client reached out
to me and she said I've actually gained some
weight and all I'm having is, and she showed
me a picture of a chicken and avocado at night
and I said, "Oh, honey, you're taking initiative
too much."
Follow exactly what it is because you're taking
in more than 44 grams of protein in one sitting
and anytime we do that we store it as fat.
So if you think, "Oh, I'm gonna have that
Atkins and I'm gonna go crazy on protein,
well if you, your body can only digest so
much at once.
That's why we break it up into meals every
two to three hours of small portions.
If you indulge like that it's stored as fat
and then she's having avocado but there's
no carb to slowly digest it so she's shocking
herself with fat too.
So the poor girl's trying to do well but she's
taking too much initiative.
What else?
>>female #1: And the timing of that, like
at night maybe but throughout the day starting
with breakfast.
>>Craig Ramsay: Yeah, well carb depleting
because a lot of people will be like, "Oh
I wanna lose weight and I gotta cut carbs
out of my diet."
No, carbs is energy, protein is repair.
So remember that, where do you need most of
your energy?
In the morning and afternoon, I'd be surprised
if you're running marathons at night but if
you are then your training's gonna be slightly
different where you're gonna need those carbs
for energy, and any marathon runner knows
this, is you're gonna have those carbs later
in the evening.
Otherwise, what you wanna do is restrict them.
Same thing with losing weight or gaining muscle,
you still don't need to have that excessive
carbs after like 3 pm.
So you wanna start cutting them out.
Snack, women definitely, and men, you want
nuts, you want, you want to have a carb like
a multi grain cracker with humus, perfect,
great.
Vegetables, do you guys have those options
here?
>>Male #3: Yeah.
>>Craig Ramsay: Yeah.
What other options, what do you guys like
to eat in the snacks here?
>>Female #2: [inaudible]
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Okay, cut the bananas, no
more bananas.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Bananas are way too high in
sugar and unless you're eating it before you
workout, great, you're gonna utilize that,
that sugar for energy, otherwise stick with
berries, blueberries, stuff like that.
My big guy in the back, how often are you
hitting the snack bar?
>>Male #4: I sit by the junk food thing
[Laughter]
>>Male #4: it's often but it's not
>>Craig Ramsay: So the junk food is like what?
Sugar stuff?
>>Male #4: Yeah, it's like candy bars
>>Male #5: there's only one
>>Male #4: Oreos
>>Craig Ramsay: Okay and when do you work
out during the day?
>>Male #4: Usually in the morning.
>>Craig Ramsay: Usually in the morning?
So if someone works out, and you lift heavy?
>>Male #4: Sometimes.
>>Craig Ramsay: Yeah?
If someone is working out to intensity and
they aren't having as much food, this should
not go on video by the way
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Cause I'm telling you how
to live an indulgent life
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: But you can have more sugar
intake.
So the less food you have the more sugar you're
able to have.
I don't wanna promote that and unless you
have a really healthy existence with incredible
workouts then you can go down that route.
That's why when you go over to Venice Gold's
you'll see cookies and you'll see brownies
being sold and you're like, "What the hell
is this?
This is a health gym."
Well it's because they need that sugar for
energy because if they went starving for 3
hours, we don't wanna have a brown rice and
chicken meal cause it's gonna be too slow
to digest, we want that fast acting sugar
to give us a sugar rush to be able to hit
our workout really hard.
Let me look at the book, I wanna get back
to the book and discuss these options in here.
I have no skin!
Ah!
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: The stretching.
We're gonna talk about stretching quickly.
It's fine if you have cramp and you're like,
"Oh I need to stretch" or before you do that
exercise you can lightly engage in a stretch.
Do not over do it.
Your body is like an elastic band, if you
overstretch that you're not gonna be able
to get a proper contraction in your workouts.
And what this book promotes is a proper stretch
and a proper contraction which you always
have to have with every single rep, every
single set.
If you don't, then you're not changing the
shape of your body.
So make sure you stretch.
If you're stretching aggressively it's after
your workout.
Now women, the exception is if you wear high
heels, but there's no dress code of high heels
here right?
No, we're pretty laid back?
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Well, if you do wear high
heels often you wanna stretch out those calves
before you begin any kind of cardio program,
okay?
Warm ups, always warm up the body, what you
wanna do is send blood flow to the body, that's
gonna help you prevent injury, that's why
we warm up for anywhere from five minutes
to 20 minutes prior to any kind of weight
resistance but you always wanna combine both
of them.
Yes?
>>Male #6: So you have a note here that the
best form of cardio is running the stairs
>>Craig Ramsay: Yes.
>>Male #6: If you could compare those to elliptical
>>Craig Ramsay: Oh gosh, I'm gonna get in
trouble again.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Christy might know what I'm
talking about.
I have to say my opinion with this and it's
the correct one, remember we talked about
that?
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: But the elliptical machine
is absolutely useless unless you have a knee
or an ankle or a lower back injury.
The reason is I go into a gym and I look at
these people that will, and I'm not judging
them, please don't think that it's a judgment,
but if you gravitate towards the elliptical
machine it means one of two things, either
you're injured and you know what you're doing
or you don't know what you're doing, you're
insecure and you jump on the elliptical machine
for 40 minutes and call it a day because it's
the easiest machine to get started and it's
the easiest machine to do.
So you're choosing the easiest machine in
a gym which is gonna give you the least results,
but guess what?
You're there and you're putting the time in
anyways you may as well go crazy on it and
go for what's going to challenge you the most
cause that's gonna change your body the most.
An elliptical machine takes the weight off
of the legs and the whole idea and point of
cardio, proper cardio program, is utilizing
the weight you have.
Like for instance Kevin, his weight loss journey,
lugging around extra weight when you need
to get rid of it, that's hard to do.
It's equivalent to me giving one of you skinny
fit people a 45 pound plate and hold onto
it and do the same cardio.
You're gonna be exhausted.
That's what an obese person feels like.
But you put them on a stairs and their going,
lugging it around it's gonna be a much harder
workout with incredible, quicker results if
you attack the stairs.
Stairs, treadmill incline, if you feel like
you're having a lazy day go on the steepest
incline possible and try not to hold on, only
10 seconds of every minute hold on, otherwise
just dig your heels down and climb that mountain.
It's gonna do you a world of good.
Do not take the easy route.
Always challenge yourself.
Does that answer it?
>>Male #6: Yep.
>>Craig Ramsay: Yeah?
>>Male #7: Related to that you were talking
about interval training with weights.
What would you recommend for interval training
with, say, running?
Pumping up the feet?
>>Craig Ramsay: For the cardio?
Yeah, what you wanna find is the amount of
time that it takes to really elevate your
heart rate.
So I'm guessing for you it'd be like a 30
second sprint.
So say you're just on a treadmill, do you
run?
Are you okay with running?
Knees good, all that?
Okay, well let's use first treadmill as an
example.
So treadmill and this is in the book as well
it'll talk about it, you know the treadmill
with handles on the side?
So we start with a two minute just easy walk
and then we bump it up to a fast speed that's
gonna really elevate your heart rate.
So I'm guessing like 6.
5, 7.0 for you, so you're running for 30 seconds,
you find the sides and you hop off carefully.
And that hop off is forcing you to catch your
breath which is lowering your heart rate.
So you calm yourself down.
Don't get wrapped up in the analyze, women
analyze everything in life too.
I'm a huge feminist so don't worry I'm not
attacking any of you but what you do is you
analyze the situation, you go in your body
and you make yourself miserable.
And what you need to do is separate that,
think about other things, trust the technique
you have because you're studying my book and
then, then you can get through that program
without over analyzing.
Over analyzing will exhaust you.
And then you grab onto the sides and you hop
back on for 30 seconds and then you do it
again.
You repeat.
That's a perfect way of interval training.
If 7.0 isn't giving your heart enough of a
challenge, the heart rate, then you have to
bump it up, bump it up, bump it up, bump it
up all the way to 12 speed.
>>Male #7: Do you recommend waiting a length
of time for the heart rate to go down or does
it lower right away?
>>Craig Ramsay: I'm guessing for you that
it would take 30 seconds after hopping off
to catch your breath.
If it takes longer then I think those intervals
are too aggressive, then you need to lower
the speed.
So raise it up and lower it down and monitor
it and you can control your heart rate to
lower.
If you relax the jaw slightly when you're
working out, and it talks about this in every
single exercise of the book, always have that
space in the jaw which is gonna allow you
to relax the back of the neck, which is gonna
allow you to breath properly.
The majority of people in the gym don't know
how to breath, believe or not, and we don't
wanna seem vulnerable and out of breath so
we hide it, right?
If you're forced to breath properly and your
diaphragm to work, if you relax that jaw it's
gonna actually lower your heart rate quicker.
So it's a trick of the trade.
150 dollars please, that's my consultation.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: fee.
Any other questions?
I like questions.
Also, if you relax the jaw and the diaphragms
working properly it's gonna take the tension
out of the neck.
You know how women, you're always saying,
"Oh, I don't wanna build big traps, my neck
muscles."
All that?
It'll be out of the equation if you do that
and then it will relax the shoulders which
will protect the rotator cli, uh, rotator
>>audience member: Cuff.
>>Craig Ramsay: Cuff, thank you and it will
also allow your diaphragm to work so you'll
be able to sing some great notes
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: like that while you're working
out.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Any other questions?
>>Presenter: Now everyone's shy.
>>Craig Ramsay: Yeah, don't be shy.
>>Presenter: Oh, here we go.
>>female #3: So, um, about routine.
>>Craig Ramsay: Yeah.
>>female #3: How often should you change your
routine cause there's always these talks about
muscle confusion.
>>Craig Ramsay: Of course, yeah, when you
become familiar with it which usually takes
6 to 8 weeks when it becomes boring.
Usually women get bored with programs sooner
than guys cause women are more capable of
processing those things and perfecting them
quicker.
No offense guys.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Just saying it like it is,
I'm one of ya, sorta.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: So with you you're gonna need
to change every 6 to 8 weeks.
And what you always wanna do is make sure
you're still combining a cardio and a resistance
program.
If it's only cardio you will get in a routine
as a woman to only burn calories from that
day and not change the shape of your body.
If you're a woman that thinks, "Oh I'm just
gonna do cardio" you're only burning calories
from the day.
You are not changing your physique.
And it's all about the ego people.
There's not one person that comes to me and
if they are they're lying if they say, "I'm
really concerned about my health and I really
would like to breath better and have balance
and all that."
I know, it's, am I allowed to say bullshit?
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: It's bullshit.
It's all about the ego.
You wanna look better and then that will change
and improve your life and, of course, your
health.
Just being honest.
Any other questions?
>>Female #4: Sorry this is a question, other
sort of cardio interval routines you can do
not just on the treadmill but maybe some of
the other machines.
>>Craig Ramsay: Absolutely.
One of my favorite cardio weight training
combination exercises is on a stationary bike,
combining dumbbell training with the bike.
So if you only have 20 minutes, 30 minutes,
this is the perfect form of cardio interval
training for all of you in this room.
Stationary bike, dumbbells and a routine of
30 second intervals, you're gonna do shoulder
presses 30 seconds, shoulder front raises
30 seconds, side push outs 30 seconds, bicep
curl 30 seconds, triceps behind the head 30
seconds and then you rest for a minute.
That's your rest, that's lowering your heart
rate and then you go back into it.
That routine in combination will shred your
body.
Absolutely shred your body and pack on upper
body mass for guys because we do have the
ability to raise testosterone levels in our
body, unlike women, so we can build our upper
body.
Women, you don't have to worry about that.
When the man does a bike in the high resistance
and we're talking for women it's anywhere
from 8 to level, 8 to level 10, for men it's
12 to 20.
If you're doing resistance training with the
legs and cardio with a really high resistance
you're bumping up your natural testosterone.
Testosterone is what makes our body composition.
It's gonna tell us how big and how cut and
how much fat we're gonna be able to lose so
you wanna give yourself a fighting chance
by raising those testosterone levels.
So that, again, goes back to our cardio, why
choose elliptical when you can work the leg
muscles and actually raise your natural testosterone
levels with stairs or with the bike on heavy
resistance?
Same thing with weight training, guys you
always wanna do legs once a week even though
we dread them.
The reason why we dread them is cause we have
that testosterone rush which makes us have
that fight or flight.
So it's panicky where you're like this and
that's relaxing the jaw, calming yourself
down and focusing and removing yourself from
the body to be able to get through the program.
Then any body part that is deficient for guys
that you're like, "Oh, I have small shoulders"
well then on the shoulder day you always incorporate
a leg exercise to the extreme, that's raising
your testosterone levels which are gonna enable
that underdeveloped body part to build.
Another 150 dollars please.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: That's a really good tip and
it's in the book
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: "The Anatomy of Muscle Building"
>>Male #8: So I actually have a quick question.
So on a leg day, would you still do cardio
on that day?
What would you suggest?
>>Craig Ramsay: Really, really good question.
You only, I only advise a warm up of like
6 minutes or so just to get the blood flowing
to the body and no cardio on that day.
Doing legs is such a cardio experience anyway
with the elevation of your heart rate going
up and down and up and down that it's not
worth it.
It's over training and you're not taking in
enough calories to justify that kind of workout.
>>female #4: Just for men?
Or women and men?
>>Craig Ramsay: For men it's also, yeah it
would be for women and men but for men it's
also a testosterone thing, they're gonna collapse.
They're not gonna have enough, what's called,
creatine and ATP levels in their body.
They don't have enough so they're actually
gonna fall down.
A woman is never gonna fall down, by the way.
This is my difference with training men and
women, men will inform me of when they're
exhausted and when they're gonna collapse,
a woman will go until her bicep rips.
And then all she'll do is go, "Oh, I'm kind
hurt a little bit.
Do you think I should be concerned?"
And her like bicep's down here.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: So that's just the difference
between men and women.
Women aren't taking in enough calories to
justify that kind of workout.
If you're spending too much time in the gym
it's useless.
You need to really focus and do it to intensity
and you make sure you eat before and after.
Another eating tip, especially for men, men
that body build you wanna eat a white starchy
carb before your workout and afterwards for
energy.
That's okay, we work out hard to indulge in
life.
So all this crap, and I can say bullshit,
so the bullshit of not having white potatoes
and not having pizza and all that stuff, it's
not true, your workouts just have to be intense
like in "The Anatomy of Muscle Building" that
justify that and utilize it.
That's what we wanna do; we wanna work out
hard to utilize that.
Yes?
>>Male #9: Does it matter what time of day
you work out?
Whether it's before breakfast or dinner or
whatever?
>>Craig Ramsay: Never before breakfast because
it's actually only, okay let's explain it
this way, you never get in a car without having
proper gas in it, right?
So your body, if it's not fueled, what is
it running on?
It's not running on calories, it's not running
on food intake, so what happens to our bodies?
Is anyone under 23 years old here?
No?
Great, so everyone 23 and older, what happens
to our body is we tap into muscle.
Unfortunately we don't tap into fat when we
work out on empty stomach.
We're too old everyone.
I hate to break it to ya, I'm with you though.
We're too old to do that nonsense so we eat
away at our muscle mass that we're trying
to put on and we convert it into fat.
That's a good way of thinking about it, smaller
here, bigger here.
You need food to work out properly.
So what was the exact question again?
>>Male #9: What time of day is best?
>>Craig Ramsay: What time of day.
When you're eating properly you wanna make
sure you have enough calories in your system,
and I'm not saying eat a buffet before you
work out because if you're new to the gym
that will make you nauseous, definitely.
So at least an hour or two before your workout
is fine and a healthy meal of maybe 500 calories
for guys, 300 calories for women, around that
range and whenever you're gonna have the most
energy.
Everyone is so different.
Or with the demands of work, if you can't
work out until the evening well then that's
your workout.
And if that's the case then we're gonna adjust
your carbs and we're gonna make sure that
you still surround yourself with carbs so
you have proper energy to work out.
If it's in the morning after your breakfast,
great, if it's twice in day like here we talked
about, if you could do half hour or 20 minutes
of cardio and then quickly change and go,
is that same fit guy or another fit guy?
>>audience: Same fit guy.
>>Craig Ramsay: He's just going, yeah, he's
going in circles.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Good observation.
He's part of the running group isn't he?
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Just around the block.
So, yeah, cardio broken up and then you go
back and you do your heavy weight lifting.
Ideal, incredible, if you guys could do that,
wow, I told you I'm signing up to Google.
Can you get me an application, Mike, afterwards?
Thank you.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: I don't know if you'll have
me but
[Laughs]
>>Craig Ramsay: After this
>>Craig Ramsay: we'll see.
Any other questions?
Do you guys have fitness groups here?
Yep?
>>Male #10: So you mentioned you were a contortionist
>>Craig Ramsay: Do you want me to prove it?
[Laughter]
>>Male #10: No, that's alright, I believe
you.
>>Craig Ramsay: My next book is a stretching
book that comes out May 15th and it's the
first time ever that I actually get to show
that off.
So I'll see you back after May 15th and we'll
do that.
[Laughter]
>>Male #10: Sounds good, I was actually wondering
what part that plays in, you mentioned don't
stretch a lot before you work out, but I wondered
what part being flexible plays in actually
not getting injured kind of in general.
>>Craig Ramsay: Absolutely you have to have
a flexible body but you have to know when
to properly stretch those muscles.
As I said, working out with weights and cardio
is a contraction.
If you elongate that muscle too much you're
gonna be flopping all around.
And I trained a lot of Broadway shows, I did
a hand full of Broadway and I was the go to
guy in Broadway and let me tell you, every
single dancer I have I have to change their
mind frame, their mind of thinking.
You know how we talked about elliptical; people
gravitate toward ellipticals for 40 minutes?
Dancers gravitate just toward just holding
their leg straight up and stretching, overdoing
it because that's their insecurity.
They don't know what they're doing so they're
gonna stretch cause they know they do it well
and they're gonna get a date out of it as
well, right?
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: It depends on what gym but,
so, with you, you still have to obtain a flexible
body.
If you work out to intensity and you don't
have time to at work here and stretch there,
then even at the office, in my next book and
I think there's a couple of stretches in here
but, again, we don't wanna look like a jackass
at the workplace and have our leg up in our
cubicle, what we wanna do is very discrete
private stretches which can be done from the
comforts of your own chair.
Which will be in the next book which I'll
definitely talk about when we return, absolutely,
and if you have a hard workout, in a hot bath
where you're raising your body temperature,
ideal way of stretching over your legs and
being able to break up that acid that makes
your hamstrings really tight.
After the workout, yeah, always, always, always,
please.
Any other questions?
Yes, Sir?
>>Male #11: So I came in late so just tell
me if I missed this question but I noticed
when stretching with a trainer my leg can
go so far back but if I just relax and let
them push instead of a pulsating motion it
keeps going farther and farther back but if
I myself am trying to do it it's a very limited
motion.
And it was mentioned that that was mainly
just a frame of mind thing that the muscle
is actually capable of tremendous kind of
relaxation when it's relaxed.
What's your thoughts on the matter?
>>Craig Ramsay: Okay, that's a PNF stretch.
So that's an assisted stretch that he's doing,
correct, with you?
>>Male #11: Yeah.
>>Craig Ramsay: It's a different form of stretching;
you need to do all types of stretching.
There's static, there's dynamic and there's
a PNF stretch which is where a trainer will
assist you and he'll even ask you for, um,
to resist him then he'll take you a little
further, that's just a different form of stretching
which you can do on your own with a towel.
So one of those hand towels, if you're on
your back and your leg is extended up, you
can do the exact same thing holding the towel
underneath your leg and then pushing against
it for a good 10 seconds and then releasing
it for another 20 to 30 seconds and that will
take the range of movement further which is
a great form of stretching but it should be
usually advised or with someone that's a professional
or a friend utilizing my next book "The Anatomy
of Stretching" on May 15th
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: which will guide you through
that.
>>Male #11: Does that cross over, does that
help for other kinds of range of motion where
you are physically moving your leg or is that
independent?
>>Craig Ramsay: Oh yes, your intimacy in the
evening, is that what you're talking about?
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Or am I going to a place that's
inappropriate at Google?
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: It helps in all forms of your
life to have a flexible body, yeah.
It helps with your relationships
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: It helps with your daily life;
sitting in a chair, repetitive movements,
having a flexible body is such a necessity.
And your lower back, you know your problem
areas and we forget to move and to make our
bodies feel good.
So taking a 15 second stretch break is gonna
make all the difference with, even with your,
your blood flow, your circulation.
Standing up and giving a stretch where needed.
If you hold your body correctly, that this
book really addresses, then you will have
less injury and less tightness in your muscles.
Any other questions?
Yes?
[Audience member mumbles]
>>Craig Ramsay: Oh, Mike has the mic.
[Laughs]
>>Male #12: So most of the exercises
>>Craig Ramsay: I thought that joke, I'm sorry;
I thought that joke would've gone over better
with you guys at Google.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Mike with the mic.
>>Male #12: It took me a second.
>>Craig Ramsay: Okay.
[Laughs]
>>Male #12: So most of the exercises in here
are actually using free weights, what's your
thoughts on sort of like belt or cable driven
machines?
>>Craig Ramsay: You guys have cable machines
correct?
They're incredible, they're great.
I think that the dumbbells and barbells are
a really good way to start and to gain your
stability.
They help with stability and your technique
before you move to cables because cables can
help you cheat a little bit more by range
of movement.
But, all exercise is great and there's not
one way, like I'm not judging weights and
cables as much as I'm judging the cardio,
still a good question.
But if it's done properly, the cable machines
are fantastic.
And machines in general are really good to
do but no one program is advised or should
be advised and, like you said, we need to
mix it up and we need to change it up.
So I'll take my clients through working a
set of dumbbells and then they'll do a barbell
press and then we'll do cable machines and
then we'll do seated, guided smith machines,
things like that.
Yeah, utilize everything that you have.
If this is what you have here don't judge
it just do it, if that makes sense.
If you don't have anything and you're at home
you can get, ah, my ultimate perfect workout
DVD.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: which I'm the perfect push
up demonstrator guy so, now it's at Costco
and stuff like that.
My DVD's there utilize the proper push up.
If you even do pushups in the correct form,
you're working all of these secondary muscles
more that what most people do as primary muscles
in the gym.
Meaning, if you have proper form, your whole
body's gonna be built from that pushup.
Any other questions?
[Pause]
>>Craig Ramsay: I have a question.
Can I get a Google shirt after this?
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: I really like them.
>>Craig Ramsay: I want the gay one though,
with the rainbow flag that's there.
[Laughter]
>>audience member: That's just the regular
one.
>>Craig Ramsay: Oh, it is?
[Laughter]
[Claps]
>>Craig Ramsay: Yay!
Google!
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Good Company.
Yeah, this is the it gets better campaign
for Google.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: That's what I need.
I'll do a PSA for Google.
Great.
>>Presenter: I think that's
>>Male #13: We could get you a Google circle
shirt.
They have these white shirts with different
colored circles.
>>Craig Ramsay: Well I love that.
I'm Canadian so we love our free shit so keep
it coming, that's great thank you.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: I'm gonna eat buffet snacks
after this, trust me.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: You'll be missing oatmeal
for a week.
[Laughter]
>>Male #14: So I have another question about
nutrition.
>>Craig Ramsay: Yeah.
>>Male #14: What should you eat to gain or
not to lose weight?
Whenever I eat healthy I have too few calories
at the end of the day and I'm losing weight
and at the same time I don't wanna eat, like,
that my blood sugar spikes too much.
>>Craig Ramsay: Right, of course, so glycemic
index, have you heard of that?
>>Male #14: Yeah.
>>Craig Ramsay: Yeah.
So Google those and make sure that you're
eating the most appropriate calorie consuming
foods possible.
That will help you in losing weight if someone's
goal is to lose weight, if your goal is to
gain weight what you're improperly doing,
if you're not seeing results and you're eating
a lot, is your workouts aren't intense enough
and you're not lifting heavy enough.
A guy has got to lift heavy in order to pack
on muscle mass cause you're ripping the muscle,
right?
You're ripping the fibers and then you're
healing them with your food.
So if you're not ripping them properly with
the proper stretch and a contraction with
every single movement then we're not changing
the shape of the muscle and we have to fill
that, uh, the damage that we do with proper
eating so you have to make sure that you're
not having breaks in your day and you have
to eat every three hours.
Think of it as meal, snack, meal, snack, meal,
snack, like you can do this, please don't
get in the habit of thinking that a protein
shake or a protein bar is a meal, right Kevin?
>>Kevin: Right.
>>Craig Ramsay: Kevin just buried his head.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: His food log with often have,
"Oh I had a Myoplex shake for dinner" and
I'm like, "It's not a meal, that's a snack!"
There's not enough healthy material in that
food to process things out of your body.
It's gonna get stuck, you need to have foods,
you need to have fiber, you need to have salad.
Is that answering your question?
Yeah?
Ask me something more specific with it.
Like for you, that pertains to you.
Ask me something like what; just ask me something
that's more specific.
>>Male #14: Well, I mean, like in general
I'm trying to, like I'm cutting out white
rice, potatoes and more bread to prevent that
my blood sugar spikes too much and then I'm
losing
>>Craig Ramsay: Do you have a problem with
that?
>>Male #14: Yeah.
>>Craig Ramsay: Okay.
That's fine.
>>Male #14: Yeah, so I've just been like losing
weight and weight like constantly.
>>Craig Ramsay: So more protein sources.
Your protein levels, do you know how much
protein you're having per meal?
Have you broken that down?
>>Male #14: No.
>>Craig Ramsay: No?
Start paying attention to that.
>>Male #14: But I mainly, by now, I'm eating
like meats with vegetables all the time.
>>Craig Ramsay: Okay, I mean, that's great
and you will lose muscle mass if you're not
having a proper carb intake but if that's
a medical issue then you need to address that
before you need to address your physique,
if that makes sense.
I would get that on track and then you can
sustain your muscle mass with more protein,
more proper proteins, so just more often,
every two hours.
You're not eating every two hours, correct?
>>Male #14: No.
>>Craig Ramsay: Right, so if you have
>>Male #14: Sometimes I'm skipping meals
>>Craig Ramsay: See, that's what's gonna do
it to you.
You're gonna lose weight.
Even if you work out hard and you don't eat
properly, it's not gonna change the shape
of your body.
Food has to be a given.
You know how people say you should start with
food or food has to be included?
No, food is a given.
It's like talent on Broadway, talents a given.
It's, then it's the other things that are
important.
So the same thing with you, every two hours
you're gonna have to have protein sources.
Hard boiled eggs here, grab hard boiled eggs
every two hours, just start feeding into that.
It gets boring but try and separate yourself
with that relationship with food and that
10 days, that's where I want you to go shit
crazy on it without any carb, obviously.
So have those options, okay?
>>Male #15: You're much too young to have
this concern but have you noticed any change
of how you metabolize and build and maintain
muscle as you get older?
>>Craig Ramsay: The majority of my clients
are 40 plus and the best results that I've
had with clients are heading into their 50s
or their 50s.
How old are you?
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Is that a,
>>Craig Ramsay: Write it down on a piece of
paper.
>>Male #15: Old enough to know better.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: So, the body changes, the
workouts have to change as you go into a different
phase.
A lot of guys go back to old school, what
worked for them in their twenties, the same
as women always judge themselves with how
they looked in high school, "Oh but I was
this weight in high school and I fit into
this."
You can't do it.
Your body has been around and been lugging
itself around and climbing up stairs.
Your muscle density is different so you're
never ever gonna weigh that same but your
physique can be the same cause muscle will
condense and look tighter.
So for guys, we have that mentality of working
out the same way we did back in the day and
you can't.
As soon as you hit a point about 45, 50, I
find, this is a stereotype, but it exists
enough that I can recommend that you change
it to a burn program.
We have pumps and we have burns and what I
mean by that is, say in this, "Anatomy of
Muscle Building" it will say okay you're doing
12 heavy sets, no, for you it's gonna be a
minute, how many can we get in a minute by
lowering the weight?
So you're doing rows like this and it's more
of a pumping rather than when you go through
the motion, when you body build, pump, pump,
your heart rate is elevated for the whole
duration of the exercise.
Remember how I talked about intervals, cardios
great for you guys?
Not the same for someone that is heading into
that age bracket, what we wanna do is your
workouts, heart rate elevated the whole time
which means you have to work out like you're
23.
You've gotta kill it.
Right Kevin?
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: Kevin how old are you?
>>Kevin: 48
>>Craig Ramsay: 48 and he changed his life
around this last year.
Completely, he looked like his father before
and now he looks like his own son, like it's
incredible.
[Laughter]
>>Craig Ramsay: You look great.
>>Kevin: I'd like to add, um, I was never
ever an athlete at all and I'm probably more
fit than I ever was in my entire life.
>>Male #14: Is that mainly the diet or exercise.
>>Craig Ramsay: Has to be, the diet has to
be a given, has to be a given.
And, especially my online training, it outlines
that but what Kevin's talking about with his
workouts is even the other day when I had
him in, uh, in training, his workouts have
to be as intense in his body as the fitness
professionals.
There's too much babysitting by trainers.
Trainers don't like me for saying this stuff
but it's true and this is why I wrote this
book is, this is your trainer, now your motivator
is you.
And that energy has got to be there, you have
to work out like the trainers work out for
themselves.
All day long I see trainers that are training
their clients and doing functional training.
Do you know what that means, functional training?
It just means like improving their daily life
for their work, for their work, for their
sports, whatever it is and I say bullshit.
I say what you need to do is work out for
a physique that's cover, Men's Health cover
worthy.
And if you have that intensity into it, change
happens.
So your work outs have to be intense.
Don't kill yourself.
I'm not trying to say that but it has to be
the proper program.
And that's in this book.
>>Presenter: Alright, well, it's 2 o'clock
so I think this is over.
Craig will be around to talk, I think, afterwards
so thank you for coming in.
>>Craig Ramsay: Thank you guys.
Thank you so much.
[Applause]